so if you ask me what is the main
challenge how we can touch everyone the
ones that it's hard for them to get the
service today uh we don't want to be
only for the private so how we can
manage the platform to be for all that's
what we look at
into 20-minute leaders just sit back
relax and learn from the leaders of
today
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by J Ventures a
Community Driven VC Fund in Silicon
Valley in partnership with low me Tech
sponsored by Homeward Ventures hippo
Insurance Upper slabs Synergy Global
hello at Stanford leap Birthright Excel
Serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm really excited to be talking
to ziv elul an entrepreneur CEO and
founder the digital advertising company
interactive which he founded together
with over yudai was sold in the first
round for 86 million dollars to the
German fiber company elul served as CEO
for 12 years of the company in 2021
fiber was sold in a deal worth 650
million dollars and in the same year
elul established a new startup called
periak he is an avid investor and board
member of several startup companies
Lieutenant Colonel and reserve and holds
a master's degree in Business the
administration with honors from the
Hebrew University and is one of its
Board of Trustees
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
I'm good thanks Michael how are you I'm
doing awesome thank you so much for
joining me today Zig thanks for having a
really a really fun conversation about
startups entrepreneurial Journeys and
you have the new of those already under
your belt say your most recent one with
period
um and looking at ADHD
um and we're going to talk about that a
little bit more previously in media
fiber Etc and so a lot for us to unpack
and I want to start
sort of chronologically and make our way
towards periapt and what you're doing
today tell me a little bit about you as
an as far as a entrepreneur what would
your journey has been like so far
I think entrepreneurs started 15 years
ago uh
I think now 17 years ago I just left the
Army
um thanks to the idea of opening a
startup together we'd offer you die
um and this journey was quite exciting
we started in uh the first adult that
was about Indian advertising the
beginning it was interactive the clue of
the mediation Exchange in the
advertising technology which we call
attack
and this company was
quite the journey isn't actually before
bed because it was uh like now that you
have the economic situation that was
poured back then it was 9 2009 and 10.
uh so we managed um to take the country
to profitability and it was successfully
acquired by a listed German company and
the name of um Fiverr
and the uh for 86 million dollars a new
after I became to be the CEO of this
list of German company
and it was 200 million on the top line
losing money
and they had 150 million euro bonds
and thanks to great management and
teamwork and strategy we successfully
managed to take the company to double
the revenue and more to be profitable
and
also was acquired the year and a half
ago by listed not the company of the
name of digital turbine for six amazing
two million dollars and um
incredible stained
less than you
and decided to move on to uh open a new
startup which is very out with two other
fathers with Gideon mayo and offering
myself that we were together like two in
a box for like 15 years and more
um we both decided to to do things that
are good for the world but in in
different segments which is uh
incredible great well I I love that give
me a you know just a a tier two Sense on
you know what what what this experience
was like for you until now so the last
14 years of of being an entrepreneur
yeah did you did you have fun did you
enjoy it yes of course swag starting
again
I don't know I've heard the
entrepreneurs are kind of insane I can
say that about myself so yeah stories
yes it's the same
um if it's fun of course I think that
you know you need it's adrenaline you
need this sound
uh working in building and creating uh I
think it's in your blood so if it was
not fun
why would we would do it you know so yes
the answer is yes definitely yes and
when it won't be fun I'm not sure that
they will manage to to continue so the
answer is yes
okay and so having fun a lot of meaning
obviously it was a big big celebration
in the end as well
doing good for the world you're
positioning yourself now you're an
entrepreneur you're saying okay there's
so many different things that I want to
be doing there's so many different
things that I could be doing I want to
do good for the world
what was that ideation process like for
you how did you get there
great question
um so the decision was to leave fibers
and I mentioned before that's one thing
um then you only start to think about
the next thing that you want to do it
was about doing startup that's something
that they knew I had options uh to go to
the visit side to being again in a
journey of taking company to a listed
company or to go to different starters
that they asked to have
um entrepreneur new entrepreneur to join
team that was raising money and capital
but the decision was to go again to a
startup that was one thing then
you need to decide which area you want
to get to go again
um so for the attack I think we had
enough the 15 years which was great
journey to do things that are good for
people at the end because you have
salaries you have
um a business to run which is exciting
also tuning because we had 200 people in
in Israel all was good
um but but I decided after my my father
was placed away two and a half years ago
from cancer that um if I'm doing
something it will be with uh something
meaningful and in health
which is to go out for my comfort zone
obviously but
I I thought that it was the right thing
to do
um and the ideation was about doing
um something in this area so the first
idea was to do something that is related
to what the fear of the rafira is doing
rubber field which is to connect on uh
between the the doctors and and the
patients
but in deviation process we understood
and like we were team gaming and and
male it's also a decision to build a
team and to have a foundation team
um and we decided that it's it's great
idea but it will be hard to execute uh
that's after turkey with some of the
visitors talking with the industry with
insurance companies and we moved to a
different idea on the digital health is
to have medication like pandemic or
something that is expensive and and we
decided to move on because we saw that
it's a field that sort of logistic
um behind it and also regulation
um so we said itself for us although
it's great idea
um to have like um Global medication for
pandemic and to manage the supply supply
chain for that
um and we we looked okay so now what and
we looked on what are the areas that it
was not been managed you have lot of
companies for cancer or you have for
mental health or you have to specific
areas but when it comes to ADHD we've
found that there is no solution
I have kids with ADHD
um daily which is also one of the found
the foundation team she knew this
material as well from area experience
and I decided to check for myself by the
way when I found on my kids I decided to
check and I found out which was not a
big surprise that I have ADHD like I
think 50 of the entrepreneurs and CEOs
which by the way this is the data and we
said okay it's it's we saw the journey
um so that it's not that easy to manage
because it's multi-discipline problem
that you need to track manage and also
to um to optimize and to personalize the
treatment
um so it is we said okay it's an area
that we know that there is a lot to do
uh we checked the the time we were
talking again with recess with the with
the market and we said okay we found out
so for your question Michael we've found
that there is a space uh there is done
we we had some Personal Collection which
is crucial
um especially if you go to digital
Health again for for me it is crucial to
have something that you are uh your
personal feeling so the decision was to
move on we raise money close to 6
million up to this is from an eventman
which was uh
uh great great because his decision was
about the foundation about the idea
about doing impact and
um he came from the same uh way of
taking like we have yes and also at
least to go on
um which is an outfit to a great for us
and and friends that joined some uh
people that are coming uh from from CEOs
of of public companies or uh uh some
overseas or Fred's pieces that joined to
the routes it was close to six million
dollars and now is that you see and MVP
and things that you know that this is
the fun part yes
I love it
okay so let's talk about periapse what
did you learn about the world of ADHD
and how you're looking at the space What
are the different things that we should
really understand about the complexity
or about the Simplicity or about the
opportunity on the table to make it a
big impact
I'm all yours yeah so first we we found
that 10 to 20 percent of the kids all
over the world
they have been diagnosed with abhd which
is
quite a lot of people in the world that
they have ADHD had put aside the ones
that have not been there because so this
is only for the ones that we know
um second we learned that
um it's multi-discipline problems so it
doesn't come with one thing it's not
that you have ADHD okay now take
communication and goodbye we we found
and and we knew but we we found by
research and also we the work that we're
doing
um with the market analysis that
usually you have ADHD but also it comes
with some emotional issues or you have
writing issues or you have
um or you need the medication no
medication or you have also the parents
that are involved that not necessarily
agree on the treatment
um and it comes also not only with the
things that we know that are great and
amazing that you can be founder and CEO
we found that you know if it's not
managed that well these kids are lost
and this gift might be in jail or uh
with impression depression uh or they
take risk and they have the more ADHD
when they grow up and and they found
themselves with more accidents
um and more divorces because of that
um so this is not the the bright side
that people are talking about ADHD we
always want to fail and rely to
the nice and the Superman and which is
all correct by the way but still you
need to manage it well in order to be on
the right side of that and and that's I
think where we can support and help and
and to strength the parents in the
process to support the kids
um because we think that
um they are the the ones to decide the
path if you're six years old seven eight
years old they take the decision so we
want to make sure that the decision they
take is is something that we can support
and help and to be 24 7.
uh for them in in the issues that they
have you have social issues that you can
manage your school issues as I mentioned
before it's a multi-discipline and you
don't have Michael holistic solution and
that's where therapy is about is to have
holistic solution and to personalize the
treatment and you can have a picture
well your kids rely to others where the
kids where your kid is in in all this uh
uh uh what we call multi-discipline uh
issues you see the old picture in school
out of school and and you can take the
right decision how to treat and how to
manage in real time
where are the challenges would
that you see in providing such a
holistic solution how how do you see
period of shaping where the different
challenges that are forming when it
comes to providing really a good
solution for somebody with ADHD I mean
what what are the complexities there
yeah the the few complexity is in in
order to scale this business obviously
like other businesses but one of the
areas that we are now looking at is the
school because the school of the wild
that they usually diagnosed what we call
previous they are they want to send the
kids for the agnostic
um so we find it as is a challenge in
the future because we we need the
cooperation so we need to make sure the
regulation wise and cooperation uh that
they will be part of the solution
because we don't want to see only one
part of the kid which is before they go
to school and after they come from
school
so this is one of the areas the second
thing is about
um
all about money money flow so if this
business will be direct to Consumer only
if it will be a bit to be to see so it's
also a chance to see it's not a
challenge it's something that that we
were now looking at them and we're
trying to analyze and understand better
um
that we can make sure that many people
will be part of the solution because we
want to to be a platform for for all
kids and not only the ones that it's
affordable for them but but for everyone
that they can't afford that we can make
sure that someone will will pay that we
can have the insurance involved and how
we can convince and how we can find the
right kpis that will enable the system
what we call the the pairs to be part of
this solution so it will be for all kids
so if you ask what is the main challenge
how we can touch everyone the ones that
it's hard for them to get the service
today we don't want to be only for the
private so how we can manage the
platform to be for all that's what we
look at
where where are you and all of this
obviously you're uh you know one of the
leaders but where is the where is Steve
as an entrepreneur and as a sort of the
world Citizen and The Game Changer what
is your vision working periapse for
yourself
I think that
um it goes back to the decision why
digital health and and why to be again
entrepreneur so for me it's it's to take
or what I know from the past
um from building companies from looking
on other companies on the side and and
to use this knowledge
um
to scale
something that can do good for for for
the world and also to make money uh I
think in the case of taking fiber 400
million dollars I want to make it for
billions here in in periap so
um and also to impact
many other people I want to make the
life of other parents that they can feel
empowered uh so that's where I find
myself as a parent
uh and also with someone with ADHD and I
know that also the other Foundation they
want the same so I think that to build
the DNA
of people that they care about others
but also they care about making money
which it's important to scale the
business it's the DNA that they want to
create
right and they as you're now creating
this DNA
you're shaping the surrounding group
together with you as you're going on
this journey
how do you align everybody and how do
you make sure that everybody's alive
Dawn on this great vision that you're
talking about because it's very easy to
say yeah I know we're all we're dealing
with you know a massive issue ADHD yeah
and all this care about it but but you
have a greater vision for the role that
periapt is going to play Within the
world of of ADHD how how do you create
that alignment
I think first is to have the right
people what I learned in the past that
people are questioned for the success
technology of course it's must
you have great Technologies but if you
don't have Team behind it that can use
this technology right so what's the
point so I think the fact that we have
first DNA of people that they work
from the same ambitious they come from
the heart to solve this solution
I think that's what I care most so the
alignment comes from first understanding
the payment not the very limited the
pain and yes the payment is also
something that really diamond is also
important
but the pain is something that people
feel
and they want to solve and if they they
connect to the pain if they talk with
parents if they have their own pain in
their home by the way and a lot of the
people now that work with with path we
have only nine people I think that seven
out of the nine or they have in HD or
they have kids with ADHD or they have
something that relied
close to them to ADHD and they feel
connect so the question the question is
amazing Michael and the answer is to
connect from your heart
to align for the Bane and then the
solution will come from from all of us
together
so it's really a teamwork
I love it no and I think it's just such
a such a cool Journey that you're on and
it's very inspiring for me as well as an
entrepreneur you know you're talking
about event wider than what you're doing
and the positive impact you're making
your own theory of change and bringing
together a phenomenal group of people
that are sharing your your theory of
change and what that means I think it's
uh I really do think it's such a such an
important story to be shared for
everybody and um and and as I'm very
thankful that you spent this time to
share with me and I'm wishing you best
of luck with your work at periap and
everything else that you'll do I look
forward to continuing from the side and
really thank you very much thank you
Michael
you make me excited this word so thank
you for the time as well